tu en es où toi c'est plus haut on est
dans ta vie toi alors tout va très bien
franchement alors là je me désole mais
pas du tout on a un grand projet oui
elle a repris le champ c'est une grande
chanteuse Fatou et donc elle fait des
cours et tout ça le prof a l'air sympa
j'ai vu ça là
c'est sympa
oui je crois mais
oui
il va lui montrer son son organe elle
voudrait participer à des castings et
n'excluez pas Cyril je sais que vous
l'aimez beaucoup moi j'aime beaucoup il
est possible qu'elle vous appelle à un
moment ou un autre pour vous proposer de
venir chanter avec vous alors après vous
réagirez comme vous voulez moi je
m'embêle pas elle m'a dit mais Cyril là
j'ai dit non moi je me mêle pas de ça
je vais chanter avec lui
un petit peu mon métier ou bien non mais
comme elle vous regarde souvent elle
sait que vous adorez danser chanter
voilà si tu me regardes voilà
Fatou je sais que tu nous regardes
puisque tu vérifies dis il est bien en
tête
c'est pas tout
je sais que le son est coupé
actuellement
sur Gilles pour qu'elle voit bien que
Gilles est là merci voilà on est en
direct Fatou tu peux continuer tes
activités
bien entendu et kiffe comme on dit kiffe
ta vie Fatou
je t'invite
dès demain ici sur ce plateau mais non à
chanter
homme femme besoin de rien envie de toi
sous le vent n'importe quoi c'est toi
qui choisis
on chantera tous les deux
s'il vous plaît monsieur Fatou
[Applaudissements]
si bien sûr mon invitation tient tu as
mon numéro
tu m'appelles quand tu veux tu sais que
Gilles et toi c'est la famille voilà
donc demain tu seras là et on chanteras
devant Gilles et Gilles te refera
certainement une demande en mariage
alors
si je peux demander un service répète
cette fois voilà c'est bon non mais je
crois qu'elle va vouloir je sais pas si
elle se sent prête à affronter cet
immense des filles mais en tout cas très
touché c'est une belle opportunité
que j'adore Fatou je suis fou
tu as de la chance que je n'attaque
jamais les meufs des amis merci
c'est pour cette Daniel a été longtemps
avec un ami à moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la réponse est non
ce soir non mais c'est exceptionnel
son mec toi
bien sûr
veiller
à tout moment forcément
[Rires]
ça me fait de la peine de dire ça donc
[Applaudissements]
je l'aime beaucoup je l'adore mais
vous le sentez pas
je pense qu'il Ken
normal
la personne
est-ce que tu veux faire un essai est-ce
que tu veux aller tout de suite chez toi
maintenant
il est pas à la maison d'ailleurs je
lance un appel à tous les conjoints
des personnes ici présentes je vais
faire ce qu'on appelle
des interroses prochainement c'est à
dire que à tout moment je peux arrêter
l'émission et envoyer des chroniqueurs
chez eux
donc si vous vous servez du fait qu'on
soit en direct pour aller forniquer
ailleurs c'est bien ça bravo
la meilleure solution
[Applaudissements]
pour être tranquille petit conseil que
je vous donne il faut Ken au sein du
plateau
de lunettes d'accord
OK
la vie ça se résume pas avoir une meuf
ou pas avoir une meuf c'est plus
compliqué que ça je pense c'est que ça
se résume à quoi avoir des meufs ou pas
en fait on dort ensemble sauf parfois
j'ai des séminaires qui durent un peu
tard toute la nuit je suis obligé de me
dormir à l'hôtel sur site
souvent avec moi alors j'ai pas fait un
séminaire de l'année oui c'est vrai
alors je tiens à dire aussi aux
chroniques
et je le dis solennellement ce soir
devant témoin
arrêtez de me prendre pour aller vite
Cyril m'a convoqué je suis resté un
petit peu plus tard avec Cyril dans la
logements
[Rires]
alors et toi tout petit parce que est-ce
que je suis déjà venu une fois dans
votre horloge
c'est un mensonge si je peux me
permettre
tais-toi parce que j'ai des énormes
dossiers sur toi
c'est une émission d'actu il faut
balancer
j'ai des énormes de saison donc fais toi
tout petit tu penses tu veux que tu
voudrais utiliser comme alibi ah oui non
c'est une question que je pose
une seule et une question
est-ce que tu penses
que j'ai des dossiers ou est-ce que tu
penses que je bluffe
je vais te la poser une deuxième
si tu dis que je bluffe même moi
et je ne rigole pas tu dis que je bluffe
je balancerai tous les dossiers enfin je
ne rigole pas sur moi
vous venez d'inviter Fatou à chanter là
[Applaudissements]